der äquator mit globetrotter der
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wert wie globetrotter punkt ch
ballonfahren ist in kenias massai mara
nationalpark üblicherweise den touristen
vorbehalten
mary macht eine ausbildung als
touristenführerin und wir ermöglichen
mir mitzufliegen
[Musik]
das erste mal dass mary keinen boden
mehr unter den füßen haben wird
ich fühle mich gut
[Musik]
doch
liebe gott steh uns bei
es ist schön aber ich habe wahnsinnig
in der vierten folge haben wir mary bei
ihrer ausbildung zur touristenführerin
begleitet zum ersten mal hat sie sich
intensiv mit weißen ausgetauscht
[Musik]
wir haben george ali nach thailand
begleitet dort hat sie große pläne
die ärztin und mode ikone will mit ihrer
kosmetiklinie einen neuen markt erobern
[Musik]
in borneo haben wir mit stammesführer
loben das leben der plan tief im urwald
kennengelernt mit moderner technik
kämpft er für die rechte seines volkes
[Musik]
what you been at katar hat die erste
reise ihres lebens angetreten
auf der insel aber young hat sie die
regierenden folgen des klimawandels in
kitas mit eigenen augen gesehen
[Musik]
unsere letzte folge beginnt mit den
weiten kenias wo ein abenteuer auf mary
wartet
[Musik]
es ist schön
zum ersten mal sieht mary die welt von
oben
ich glaube da hinten ist ein elefant
[Musik]
es ist ein bisschen wie der lift den ich
genommen habe als ich einmal in europa
[Musik]
wenn die landschaft einen hügel steigt
dann der balloon automatisch wenn ich
heiße luft hinein glaser geht der ballon
hoch und wenn ich sie ab lasse die
darunter
manchmal hilft ein wenig abstand um zu
sehen wie sehr man etwas liebt
[Musik]
in unserem land gibt es kühle und
schwarze menschen
ich fühle mich hier sehr wohl auch weil
die leute meine sprache sprechen
[Musik]
in borneo kehren lumen und seine freunde
von ihrer mission zurück
[Musik]
so sieht es aus in die holzfäller
zugeschlagen haben
[Musik]
eins bleibt noch zu tun
dupont will den kahlschlag filmen
[Musik]
ein gefährliches unterfangen denn die
holzfäller arbeiten mit dem segen der
regierung die straße die sie zu dem
abholzen geschlagen haben
betrachten sie als ihren privatgrund
[Musik]
unser übersetzer james wird leben
begleiten wir fahren runter ins tal
hinter gegend von joby ich hoffe wir
können ein team von holzfällern sehen
und dokumentieren wie sie die bäume
fällen
um nicht aufzufallen wollen lupen und
james mit dieser kleinen kamera filmen
wir müssen diskret vorgehen
die holzfäller hätten sicher keine
freude wenn sie sehen würden dass wir
sie filme
[Musik]
hier hat gabun in seiner jugend gelebt
und gejagt
heute sind über zwei drittel seines
stammes gebietes abgeholzt
[Musik]
jetzt wollen sie möglichst nah an die
holzfäller herankommen
[Musik]
wahrte damit man die kamera nicht zu
kurz der benzintank für die bagger mit
denen sie unseren wald abholzen
[Musik]
nun muss sich beeilen will er das
weniger retten was von seinen
regenwälder noch geblieben ist
[Musik]
für die republik clippers mit ihren 33
inseln kommt jede rettung zu spät
noch bevor die inseln als folge des
klimawandels untergehen werden sie nicht
mehr bewohnbar sein
gotovina besucht auf der insel aber jan
ein dorf hier leben all jene die ihre
heimat bereits verloren haben musste er
vor der mir hierhin schichten
das stimmt in unserem alten dorf kommt
wir nicht mehr leben
wir mussten alle umziehen jetzt sind wir
hier
dort hatten wir alles unsere häuser
unser gemüse das meer hat alles zerstört
das meer war überall
es kann von allen seiten wir konnten
nichts mehr anbauen
das grundwasser versalzen wir hatten
keine chance
wir haben das hier alles alleine
aufgebaut und wie fühlt es sich an nicht
mehr direkter mir zu leben das ist haut
ich wollte nicht glauben dass mir das
eines tages passieren würde
[Musik]
auf ihrem gang durchs dorf schaut jutta
biener in ihre eigene zukunft
[Musik]
wenn auch sie und ihre familie den
fluten weichen müssen
[Musik]
schauen sie sich unser neues dorf an
früher waren wir nah am meer wir konnten
den fisch stehen wir gefangen haben
direkt essen
wir hatten jede menge platz hier hatten
wir alle aufeinander
unser priester sagt eines tages werden
wir alle ins ausland müssen
ich sage dazu warum nicht welchen sinn
hat es hier zu bleiben und etwas neues
aufzubauen wenn am ende doch wieder
alles vom meer verschwindet dann lieber
ganz weg in eigentlich kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen
aber warum kämpfen wenn das meer am ende
auf mein dorf wird wohl eines tages von
mir weg gespült werden
[Musik]
mary hat wieder festen boden unter den
füßen als er landete dachte ich es würde
rütteln aber besonders beeindruckt ist
mary von piloten und von seinen beruf
was musstest du machen um ballon pilot
zu werden
es ist einfacher geworden mit diesen
dingen
ich bin fürs training drei monate nach
kalifornien gegangen dann kam ich nach
kenia um hier meine lizenz zu machen
jetzt bin ich dran weitere flugstunden
zu sammeln
marys feier ist entfacht
doch sie wird unterbrochen
es ist das denn ein erfrischungstuch vor
dem essen
das hat mehr wie noch nie bekommen alles
für die touristen ihr lebt wirklich
inhaltlich das frühstück mitten in der
savanne gehört zum touristenprogramm ja
so viel geld um es für solche dinge
auszugehen wenn ich früher in der luft
einen ballon gesehen habe dachte ich was
machen die leute da diesen komisch aber
nun weiß ich wie schön das ist
mary ist auf bestem weg
touristenführerin zu werden jetzt hat
sie bereits einen neuen traum wenn du
ballonpiloten werden möchtest dann go
for it
das ist schon was tolles
es gibt nur einer massai piloti ja bitte
den kenne ich
er hat uns mal gesagt ich habe jetzt
einen titel nennt mich nicht mehr
einfach in japan sondern dr
marys plan ist gefasst ich will
ballonpiloten werden ja wie gesagt er
ist einer von vier afrikanern hier in
kenia die ballonpiloten sind und ich
wäre dann die erste frau
doch eins nach dem anderen beim safari
frühstück nimmt sie zuerst mal kontakt
mit ihren zukünftigen kunden auf
[Musik]
der ton kämpfer loburg er zurück in sein
dorf
[Musik]
willkommen in meinem dorf jetzt gehen
wir zu meinem haus
[Musik]
lang lang
die großeltern von blumen haben die uhr
waldsiedlung in den 50er jahren
gegründet
[Musik]
bis in die 90er jahre lebten die planer
aber nur hin und wieder hier die meiste
zeit zogen sie als nomaden durch die
umliegenden wälder
und dann kann man vor 20 jahren die
holzfäller in unterzahl
jetzt gibt es hier können bei mir bald
mehr wie früher alles noch gewachsener
sekunden lebt in einen von ihm selbst
erbauten haus zusammen mit seiner frau
und drei kindern
[Musik]
sie sind selbstversorger und auf einen
intakten urwald angewiesen
wir sollten mehr gäste einladen damit
sie sehen was hier passiert dann würden
sie unsere probleme auch besser
verstehen
ja
[Musik]
die ärztin und unternehmerin george ali
ist in bangkok unterwegs sie die nichts
weniger als die estée lauder von asien
werden will hat einen termin mit einem
geschäftsmann
er soll ihr helfen ihre kosmetikprodukte
in thailand zu vertreiben
eine art startschuss zur rallye will
später in weitere asiatische märkte
eindringen
der mann hat verspätung
zeit für uns georgiers langjährige
mitarbeiterin zu fragen wie es ist immer
für georgia da zu sein
ich wusste nicht dass ich so vieles aus
meinem leben machen kann
dieser möglichkeit hat sie mir gegeben
[Musik]
schließlich kommt er georgiers
hoffnungsträger er soll ihr in thailand
die türen öffnen
sorry für die verspätung
kein problem dieser verkehr aber auch
gestern standen wir zwei stunden im
stand
jared avatar ist spross einer
einflussreichen familie und mitbesitzer
einiger der größten einkaufszentren
bangkoks
sein markenzeichen ein
unerschütterliches selbstvertrauen
reiche können raub sein du musst vor
allem an das glauben was du tust
erstens glaube ich an meine freundin
georgia und 21 an ihre produkte
die sind gut für mich ist es eine
herausforderung
ich bin ein geschäftsmann ich liebe es
schwierige dinge anzupacken
ich will gewinnen ich gebe niemals auf
dieser mann macht dinge möglich das habe
ich schon oft erlebt
ich kenne ihn zu der sorte männer die an
versprechen halten und zu jenen die den
wert diskreter verhandlungen zu schätzen
wissen
die kamera soll auf abstand gehen
[Musik]
zum schluss noch ein augenschein in der
kosmetikabteilung des einkaufszentrums
dann muss george ali zurückfliegen nach
singapur ihre anderen leben warten schon
bald wird sie weiter durch ihre agenda
setzen schütze glücklich menschen
aber dieses glücksgefühl ist bei mir nur
von kurzer dauer
ich habe noch nicht wirklich erreicht
was mein unterbewusstsein mir als ziel
vor
die zeit drängt doch einen ort will
georgia unbedingt noch aufsuchen
[Musik]
auch auf borneo bleibt wenig zeit für
die rettung des urwalds lupen und james
haben genügend informationen und
beweismaterial zusammen um rechtlich
gegen das abholzen der regenwälder
vorzugehen
die land rechtslage und die kartierung
sind ein zentrales projekt des uno
manser fonds in dessen rahmen auch nun
ausgebildet wurde vor ein paar jahren
erhielt jedoch zusätzlich von einer
malaysischen universität und einer
japanischen stiftung eine internet
station
hier kontrollieren loben und james immer
wieder wie sich die situation ihrer
wälder vom satelliten aus betrachtet
verändert
[Musik]
ein zoom auf das stammesgebiet der plan
aufs dorf long lama an der grenze zu
indonesien
die hellen stellen sind die abgeholzten
gebiete
[Musik]
da sind wir letzte woche durchmarschiert
was wollen sie uns jetzt auch noch
bequem
schau mal hier die ersten holzfäller
straßen
man kann sehr gut sehen wo sie abholzen
[Musik]
unglaublich man sieht jede einzelne
straße
das weiße hier das sind die allerersten
pionier straßen in einigen jahren wird
da kein urwald entstehen
[Musik]
vielleicht wird der urwald in einigen
hundert jahren wieder sein wie früher
aber für uns gehen alle wertvollen wald
pflanzen verloren
[Musik]
das wird auf der karte wahnsinnig gut
deutlich
für mich zeigt die karte hier den tod
hier ist kein leben mehr möglich wenn
der urwald einmal zerstört ist ist er
für immer zerstört unser gedächtnis ist
es einmal weg ist unsere kultur weg für
immer in den gerodeten gebieten gibt es
keine großen bäume keine heilpflanze
alles weg nichts ist mehr da die ganze
gegend hier ist wie eine wüste
jetzt wollen sie retten was noch zu
retten ist
[Musik]
eigentlich ist clippers das was man sich
unter einem paradies vorstellt
doch wie lange wird dieses paradies noch
existieren
[Musik]
es ist sonntag zeit für die große messe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
youtube sucht trost nach dem
deprimierenden erkenntnissen der letzten
tage
[Musik]
liebe gemeinde im namen des vaters des
sohnes und des heiligen geistes auf
pater martin ruhen die hoffnungen der
gemeinde viel trost können sie bei ihm
allerdings nicht finden
es hat keinen sinn jetzt darüber zu
streiten wer schuld ist am klimawandel
wir müssen den tatsachen ins auge
schauen früher oder später werden wir
unsere insel verlassen müssen und dafür
müssen wir gerüstet
wir müssen uns gedanken machen
wir können nicht abwarten bis es zu spät
ist wir müssen uns jetzt bereits darauf
vorbereiten dass wir eines tages gehen
müssen
unser präsident hat bereits anfragen
anderer länder gestartet ob sie uns eine
neue heimat bieten können bereitet euch
vor wir werden alle gehen müssen
[Musik]
die worte des abendmahls in kerbers
haben sie eine nahezu symbolische
bedeutung
und er sagte zu ihnen trinket alle
daraus dies ist mein blut das für viele
vergossen wird zur vergebung der sünden
hunderttausend menschen bislang kann
oder will sie kein anderes land
aufnehmen
und selbst der priester hat wenig
mitleid
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir können jetzt nicht kommen und sagen
gott soll uns helfen
gott hat uns verantwortung für die welt
gegeben die er für uns erschaffen hat so
steht es schon in der bibel erst hat
gott die welt erschaffen
dann habe er den menschen geschaffen und
ihm aufgetragen seine verantwortung
gegenüber der schöpfung wahrzunehmen
ich denke gott erzählen teil getan jetzt
müssen wir selber schauen
nach der messe bleibt nur eine person
zurück in der kirche
gott hat mir kraft für meinen weg durchs
leben gegeben
ich gebe die hoffnung nicht auf dass er
mir und meiner heimat am ende doch noch
helfen wird vielleicht werde er doch
noch alles gut werden für uns ein
caritas
[Musik]
jutta biener wird zurückkehren auf ihre
insel
[Musik]
und sie wird hoffen dass das wasser doch
nicht kommt dass ihre familie um dir
dort verschont bleiben
dass gott in ordnung bringt was der
mensch zerstört
[Musik]
auch george ali will sich vor ihrem
rückflug nach singapur noch an die
himmlischen mächte wenden
[Musik]
nein
die vor fast budapest städte im herzen
von bangkok der grund für georgiers
besuch bereits bei ihrem letzten bangkok
business trip war sie hier und hat sich
etwas gewünscht
[Musik]
damals hat sie das versprechen abgegeben
zurückzukehren wenn der wunsch in
erfüllung geht
[Musik]
und charlie ist zurückgekommen
mit dabei hat sie gleich einen neuen
wunsch aber auch der wird ihr geheimnis
bleiben
und so wartet dieser schillernde society
lady und unternehmerin auch hier die
fassade mit bleibt letztlich
geheimnisvoll
[Musik]
heute wollen die pen an die ergebnisse
von lupus mission anschauen
es sind die letzten beweisstücke für
ihre land rechtslage zusammen mit
weiteren stammes mitgliedern willuhn
jetzt die zeilen formulieren die die
zerstörung der wälder stoppen sollen
sie sind die würdenträger des dorfes für
sie ist der urwald ihr leben
sie wollen nicht mehr dulden dass dieses
leben abgeholzt wird
nun ist der mensch auf den sie jetzt
ihre hoffnung setzen
während der letzten woche hatte mit
einem gps-gerät historisch bedeutsame
orte der plan im urwald vermessen orte
die sein volk schon seit generationen
benutzt mit der karte wollen die pen an
beweisen dass sie ein anrecht auf irland
haben
wir haben jetzt 60 aus sorgen
zusammengetragen
es ist wichtig dass alle namen stimmen
ich garantiere dass hier jeder name
korrekt ist nach mehreren stunden steht
der entwurf
[Musik]
ich glaube wir haben alle wichtigen
informationen zusammengetragen
ich habe große hoffnung und denke wir
werden den fall gewinnen
schließlich ist das ja unser land hat
sie nicht gewinnt gibt es einen anderen
weg
dann würden wir den fall weiterziehen
am ende werden wir auf jeden fall
gewinnen ich bin stolz darauf dass wir
kennen uns nun selbst organisieren und
unser schicksal in die eigenen hände
nehmen
natürlich brauchen wir auch
unterstützung von außen aber nur wenn
wir geschlossen zusammenstehen können
wir wirklich etwas errechnen
vor ein paar jahren haben wir vom volk
der bahn auf zara gehört
sie haben auch für ihr land gekämpft sie
sind vor gericht gegangen und haben
gewonnen
deshalb hoffen wir dass wir auch
gewinnen werden die ehemaligen nomaden
sind sesshaft geworden aber ihre seelen
sind noch immer im urwald der sie umgibt
zu hause
deshalb wollen wir jetzt endlich die
rechte über unser land bekommen dann
können wir auch unseren urwald schützen
das ziel ist zum greifen nah es fehlt
nicht mehr viel nur wenige planen
verlassen den wald ihrer vorväter und
gehen weg in die stadt
sie haben sich für ein leben abseits der
verlockungen der modernen welt
entschieden
und sie wünschen sich dasselbe wie wir
alle
das waren ihren lebensraum nicht
zerstört mary und ihre schulkolleginnen
sind auf dem weg zur nächsten lektion
plötzlich unerwartete besuch
manas so ist ein idol für die
schülerinnen
sie gehört zu den ersten frauen die
touristen durch die masai mara führen
wie geht es dir meine liebe mir geht es
kurz wie geht es in der schule sehr gut
alles ist okay wir sind glücklich in der
schule zu sein das ist toll
ich hatte meine erste auto freistunde er
ist ein richtig cooler lehrer
er bringt uns alles über die tiere und
die natur bei er ist wirklich gut und
wir haben sogar französisch alle frauen
an der schule wollen sein wie man lasse
auch mary balazs so hat es geschafft sie
hat einen job und verdient das geld ihr
eigenes geld
es ist sehr wichtig vorbilder zu haben
frauen die zeigen dass man es schaffen
kann
lehrer michael ist stolz er musste für
seine schülerinnen kämpfen mit den
ersten drei frauen die wir vor neun
jahren in der schule hatten gab es viele
probleme
niemand glaubte dass frauen vor allem
marcel frauen einen job im tourismus
machen könnte
das war einfach ein manager als wir sie
ins praktikum in die lodges schicken
wollten dieses es gebe keine
schlafplätze für sie wir mussten zelte
für sie kaufen die manager wollten keine
frau zwischen wollen alle lieber frauen
anstellen als männer
bei den letzten schulabgängern gab es
nur eine frau die keinen job gefunden
hat
die nachfrage noch frauen ist inzwischen
größer als die nach männern
das idol persönlich will mary rausfahren
zur nächsten lektion in der savanne
lehrer michael sieht auch in mary eine
frau die ihren weg ganz sicher machen
wird und mary wäre nicht mehr hätte sie
nicht schon eine genaue vorstellung von
diesem weg wenn ich die schule beendet
kann ich auto fahre ich bekomme einen
job und werde kühe kaufen und meiner
mutter ein schönes haus bauen wenn ich
das alles gemacht habe will ich eine
ausbildung zur ballonpiloten machen und
ganz zum schluss
[Musik]
marys geschichte ist nur eine von vielen
am äquator
er scheint so weit weg und doch stehen
die schicksale der menschen dort für
einige der großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit
[Musik]
in cary bassist ihr turbine in ihr dorf
zurückgekehrt
ehemann katar zimmert weiter an den
stabileren haus um seiner familie mehr
schutz vor dem mehr zu bieten und jutta
biener versucht mit den mitteln die ihr
zur verfügung stehen den untergang ihres
paradies es hinauszuzögern
und george ali sie konnte ihre ersten
kosmetik verträge mit bangkok
unterzeichnen
mit dem neuen asiatischen
selbstbewusstsein treibt sie sich und
ihre mitarbeiter weiter voran
und wer weiß vielleicht wird man eines
tages lesen können george ali die estée
lauder von asien
kämpfer wie lou braucht die welt um ihre
ressourcen zu schützen
die klage gegen das abholzen ihrer
urwälder ist eingereicht
nun warten gewinn und seine mitstreiter
auf die gerichtsverhandlung die welt
ihre vorväter
sie darf nicht untergehen
[Musik]
emi gehört den besten schülerinnen ihres
jahrgangs bald wird sie als
touristenführerin ihr erstes eigenes
geld verdienen
und vielleicht derzeit auch noch
ballonpiloten
[Musik]
träume sind des menschen antrieb und am
ende sind diese träume vielleicht gar
nicht so unterschiedlich
hier bei uns und dort am äquator den
breitengrad denn extreme
[Musik]
der äquator mit globetrotter dem
spezialist für niedere die reisewelt wie
globetrotter punkt ch